العربيه تحتفل غدا بمرور 20 عاما على
تاسيسها
امريكا تقترب من حظر التيك توك بشكل كامل
في اراضيها
وزوجه حكيمه تشعل السوشيال ميديا ببدئها
اجراءات الطلاق
هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم من قناه
العربيه فاهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
بمناسبه مرور 20 عاما على تاسيسها تحتفل
قناه العربيه غدا الجمعه في تغطيه خاصه
لهذا الحدث وتشمل هذه التغطيه المباشره
التي ستمتد لساعات فقرات عده تتضمن
الحديثه عن كيفيه احداث قناه العربيه
تغييرا في الساحه الاعلاميه العربيه لكي
يبقى المشاهد على معرفه اكثر فيما ستبدا
التغطيه بحلقه خاصه من برنامج صباح
العربيه الذي سيستضيف مجموعه من
الاعلاميين الحاليين والسابقين في القناه
وضيوفا في مجالات مختلفه للحديث عن التطور
وتوسع الكبير الذي شهدته القناه والعالم
بكافه المجالات على مدى العشرين عاما
الماضيه
بعدما اعلنت روسيا رسميا ان قواتها تتعامل
مع هجوم تخريبي نفده مسلحون اوكران في
منطقه بريانس في الحدوديه اكد نائب في
البرلمان الروسي ان بوتين سيتراس اجتماعا
طارئا لمجلس الامن الروسي في وقت لاحق
لمتابعه الحدث غير المسبوق وكان حاكم
مقاطعه اكد في بيان ان المجموعه
الاوكرانيه نفذت عمليات اجراميه وارهابيه
خلفت قتلى وجرحى كما احتجزت رهائن فيما
اعلنت وكاله الامن الفيدراليه الروسي انه
يجري حاليا البحث عن مخربين اوكرانيين في
مناطق بالقرود وكورسك الحدوديه
وفتحت تحقيقا بالهجوم
الى امريكا الان حيث صوتت لجنه النيابيه
اليوم لمصلحه مشروع قانون من شانه ان يسهل
على مجلس النواب حضر تطبيق تيك توك الصيني
في البلاد لجنه الشؤون الخارجيه في مجلس
النواب التي يقودها جمهوريون اقرت مشروع
قانون ردع الخصوم التكنولوجيين لامريكا
لكن النص سيواجه معارضه نشطاء في الدفاع
عن حريه التعبير والديمقراطيين عندما يطرح
على التصويت في مجلس النواب والشيوخ فيما
قال الرئيس اللجنه ان المشروعه يفرض حظر
اي تطبيقات برمجيه تهدد لان القومي
للولايات المتحده
في خبر اثر تفاعلا واسعا في مواقع التواصل
افادت تقارير بان الرجل الذي كان له اليد
طول في تصفيه وطرد الموظفين في تويتر قد
يحل مكان ايلون ماسك مدير التنفيذيا
للشركات موقع اوضح ان هو اول من صعق
الموظفين بقرارات التسريح والطرد المقر
الرئيسي لتويتر في الاسابيع الاولى
لاستحواذ ماسك على الشركه مشيرا الى ان
الاخير اعتمد على تنفيذ سياسه صرف
الموظفين لدرجه انه استطاع خفضا مليار
دولار من تكاليف تشغيل تويتر بعدما كان
مطالبا بخفض 500 مليون دولار فقط
في خبرنا الاخير افادت وسائل اعلام بان
الممثله الاسبانيه من اصول عربيه هبه بوك
بانها بدات اجراءات الطلاق من زوجها
اللاعب المغربي اشرف حكيمي بعد اتهامه
بالاغتصاب مؤخرا من قبل فتاه في فرنسا
موقع السير ديجيتال اوضحها في تقرير له ان
عبوك وحكيمي كان يفكران بالانفصال منذ
فتره مشيرا الى قضيه الاغتصاب المزعومه
جاءت لتسرع العمليه اكثر فيما تاتي الخطوه
الممثله الاسبانيه بعد ساعات قليله من
تصريح لحكيمه نففيه تلك المزاعم واكد انها
خاطئه تماما